قال المبعوث الخاص لرئيسي مجلس السياده في
السودان دفع الله الحاج علي للجزيره ان
المبادرات السياسيه الان محصوره في تحقيق
وقف اطلاق النار وتقديم مساعدات انسانيه
فقط
المبادرات
محصوره الان فقط في تحقيق
الهدنه واخف اطلاق النار تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه فقط اما مساله
الحل النهائي هذا ستقوم به الحكومه بعد
حسم هذا التمرد وستكون هنالك عمليه سياسيه
موسعه
يشرف عليها
تشرف عليها الحكومه ويشارك فيها جميع
السودانيين بدون استثناء واشار المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
للجزيره الى ان الجيش السوداني قادر على
الحسم لكنه لا يستخدم القوه المفرطه حفاظا
على ارواح المدنيين واشار دفع الله الحاج
علي الى ان الجيش السوداني لا يشارك
مباشره في المفاوضات الجاريه امام وصفهم
بالمتمردين
واكد ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه قادره
قادره لكن هي توازن بين استخدام القوه
المفرطه
والخسائر التي يمكن ان تقع على مواطنينا